à 27 ans charles zanon est à la tête de
sa marbrerie
mais il est aussi et surtout tailleur de
pierre le jeune homme originaire de bol
n'est pas arrivée là par hasard
c'est une star un petit peu familial
c'était à la base de métier de mon grand
père que j'ai repris c'est un métier
qu'on traîne dans nos gènes depuis
plusieurs générations chez nous et ça
s'est arrêté la génération de mes
parents et moi j'ai un petit peu reprise
flambeau déjà quatre ans que cet artisan
est installée dans des locaux qu'il
vient de moderniser
il n'a pas hésité à participer à ces
journées européennes des métiers d'art
même s'il ne cautionne pas la totalité
du concept européenne
je sais pas pourquoi un puisque c'est
quand même souvent à ces régionales on
va dire surtout dans nos pays dans nos
régions plutôt peut-être à paris c'est
différent voilà européenne en a pas
je comprends pas bien le sens un peu
plus loin dans la tranquillité des
maranges sylvie et françois freynet
vaquent à leurs occupations quotidiennes
dans leur atelier de poterie
pendant que madame pain monsieur tour de
la glaise sous le regard intrigué des
visiteurs d'un jour
c'est un un moment où tout le monde peut
découvrir des métiers voire des artisans
en train de travailler et ça c'est
passionnant ces journées on est du coup
on se rend disponible pour le public
peut faire les démonstrations pour faire
le tout ce que le public a envie qu'on
fasse le reste de l'année mais qu'on ne
fait pas pas souvent on essaye de
montrer un peu toute la richesse la
complexité de ce métier il ne vous reste
plus que ce dimanche pour profiter de
cette opération portes ouvertes et
peut-être découvrir l'atelier d'un
artisan près de chez vous